we're gonna give you guys some booster
packs but more so familiar with Yukio
and Pokemon I have not at all heard
about magic so complete you have been
playing off and on for like maybe just a
couple years total length of time
between when I started and now like 17
years but there was a big gap we spent
some time apart we found ourselves back
together again and this has been fun
we're like kind of finding the romance
that's great I have no idea the rules
what you can do and it seems kind of
overwhelming Magic the Gathering is the
world's premier trading card game it
premiered back in 1993 basically you
bring a deck of cards that you build
yourself you have 20 life they have 20
life and if you can get them to 0 before
they get you to 0 you win the game has
now played by millions of players around
the world and it's like no other game
really out there there's also a really
cool story elements of the game there's
an entire lore there's characters can
follow the character's story as we go
through the sets I don't know what it is
about the fantasy realm it's like you
look around at the world right now who
doesn't want to escape that for a minute
it's like a comfort world in the way
that maybe like a family sitcom is these
timeless themes there's always gonna be
else or it's two minutes swords who
can't say that they wish they could
settle you know in office dispute with a
two sided axe now and then
mr. Baxter I'm getting very strong like
the Leah Queen of the Damned by
Cleopatra
she's pretty fire what are you getting
there I mean it's up front this it's a
new card smell the centers deliverance
this reminds me Beyonce for sure oh my
god the oxygen and a magic cards I have
a t-rex here too maybe he's not a t-rex
oh he's a crocodile well he's very big
evolution yo I have cancel cancel on car
like cancel your life alright I'm seeing
a ripped man Cobra yeah Jack yo he's
Jack he's obviously the thing is is what
he's working out five to seven times a
week it's not realistic that most dudes
have bodies like this so don't be
intimidated when you see these dudes of
these bodies to be like wait he has a
man Cobra trainer he is a man Cobra
trainer this whole lifestyle so he's not
just having this yeah you know it's it's
a commitment wizard psychosis here these
are only the engineers of our childhood
imagination they inspired a whole
generation a whole genre of gaming we
put your magic eight hours a day and and
we still want to go to work every day I
am excited to teach BuzzFeed people how
to play magic magic is a game of threats
and answers you're gonna play creatures
to threaten your opponent your opponent
is going to attend themselves this will
continue till one of you emerges
victorious officially and
magic comfort the person helping us
Melissa she after a while it was like
giving us less instruction is because we
were able to actually go with the flow
of the game like everything I talked her
like oh my god I get it
oh my god it hit me I understand she
decides to take the strategy behind it
really was up to you when you wanted to
bring a certain card out I've gotten an
instant yes it's to be played during
another soul absolutely you can direct
him all you want you can sure once I
bought into it like oh I'm tap tap
strategy sorcery yeah attack her beat
her all done but look at us see you
really using all the magic Lambo now we
now we like know what people are talking
about when someone starts playing for
the first time and they get this scope
of like what's going on and how deep you
can go it's kind of like you can see it
and that's fun to see
the art was beautiful you can just tell
how much care went into every aspect in
every carve you just have this vision in
your mind of what it's doing on the
battlefield I would say to people who
haven't tried magic yet don't be
overwhelmed once you just start
digesting and actually seeing people
play it it's super tangible and super
accessible being out there seeing all my
co-workers smelling the cards feeling
the sleeve you've never lost a spot it
was so much fun I want to get better in
a place where I can bust out my deck
like let's go watch our curious
[Music]